hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead
today i'm going to explain a 2020
american fantasy movie called upside
down magic
the movie begins with nori who discovers
her magical power while looking at a cat
whiskers suddenly appears and she
somehow manages to transform herself
into the exact cat her father is shocked
when he learns that his daughter can
also pull out wings in her cat
form six years later she reveals that
she is going to the sage academy a place
where every magic teenager like her is
trained to control their abilities
meanwhile nori's best friend reina
carvajal also has a superpower which is
to control fire it seems like nori is
having a hard time controlling her skill
she can transform into a cat but with a
beaver's tail and kangaroo's body shape
long story short the girls and the other
students gather at the roadside they are
then welcomed by scriff who reveals that
the academy is located inside the woods
while walking nori tries to interact
with one of the students but it seems
like he is not interested in talking to
her the group eventually arrives at a
portal nori and reyna enter the portal
and are very impressed with the
environment of the sage academy where
every student is given freedom to
express their powers
ms knightslinger the headmaster of the
academy gives them a warm welcome
telling them that they are going to be
trained to develop their magic in the
sage way
she then explains that sage will put the
students into five groups based on their
talent which are fuzzies who communicate
with animals
flickers who can pull an object toward
them
flares who control fire
flyers who can fly and fluxers who have
the power to transform into any animal
at their will
however she adds that the students are
required to take a placement test to
identify which of them are worthy to
join the honors level classes
the flares candidates are asked to light
up a candle from a distance
every student passes the test smoothly
until a boy elliot cohen who casts smoke
instead of fire
finally it is reyna's turn and the
assessors are impressed
next the flyers are tested to fly low
and hold their position for 30 seconds
this time andres instead of flying low
he flies high and is unable to come down
until scriff helps him with stairs the
flickers candidates are told to pull the
vase toward them from a distance however
paloma's power allows her to push the
objects instead of pulling it almost
hitting the assessors
move to the fuzzies the candidates are
required to guess the dog's name
favorite food etc correctly
finally the fluxers candidates have to
hold their kitten form for 6 seconds
it's nori's turn
as expected she transforms into a kitten
with dragon's wings which disappoints
the assessors because she is different
after every student is assessed they are
told to see the test result
rayna gets her place into the flair's
honor level class while nori receives
udm class which stands for upside down
magic the sage students will practice in
the building and will be given a uniform
but the udm students have to accept the
fact that they will be learning in an
underground bunker it is then revealed
that all students who failed in the
placement test are sent to the udm class
including nori she still doesn't want to
accept the reality feeling that she was
outstanding in the test instead of
practicing magic they will study school
stuff like math with scrift to keep them
productive until their magic fades away
ms nightslinger shows up and explains to
the udms that they are unteachable and
will be a threat to humanity since the
udms are prone to shadow magic which
cause chaos and destruction
thus they have to let their magic die
and live as a normal human being
on the other side reina attends her very
first training where the teacher tells
them that two best students from each
talent will be chosen to represent the
school in the sage match
the winner of the match will perform in
the upcoming the annual founders day to
sharpen her firebender skill reina is
told to pop popcorn using her fire she
is distracted and the popcorn becomes
overcooked which disappoints the teacher
a girl named chandra secretly observes
reina the next day nori is very excited
because she thinks that they are going
gonna practice to control the flying
broom but it is just a normal broom and
they are ordered to sweep trash
nori comes across the fluxers who are
taking notes of what the teacher is
saying and secretly following the class
she intervenes and tries to prove
herself in front of the others as
expected she turns into a weird creature
instead
scriff warns her not to do it again at
lunch reina does not interact with the
others while nori becomes closer to her
new friends
reina suddenly becomes very excited when
she sees her best friend
however as she walks toward her a
teacher appears and stops her telling
her that they don't interact with udms
not giving up nori tells her friends
that she plans to show up at the sage
match to show everybody that udms are
still worthy the following day all the
students including the udms keep
practicing and improving their power at
some point the teacher is satisfied with
one of the students popcorn while reyna
still struggles to make a perfect
popcorn
she finally does not overcook it but the
teacher is unimpressed with the taste
the overwhelmed reina meets chandra who
offers her help to unlock her potential
she then finally catches up with nori
pretending that she is okay
at the library reina suddenly discovers
a black mysterious book
since then the book keeps following her
that night nori prepares for the sage
match but her friends are pessimistic
since she keeps mutating into other
animals
meanwhile reyna eventually opens the
book where the shadow magic is summoned
possessing rayna's body at the sage
match she becomes extremely good with
her firebender skill and wins the match
against her rival meaning that she will
perform at the founder's day
suddenly a wild nori appears and once
again tries to prove herself to the
assessors unfortunately she fails again
she transforms into a huge terrifying
creature and reina casts a powerful
fireball attacking her best friend she
apologizes to her since she still
doesn't understand why she becomes very
strong
ms nightslinger becomes furious and
threatens to terminate the udms if they
don't comply
her friends are very disappointed with
nori thinking that nothing can change
their fate as the upside downs
scriff finally confesses that he feels
bad seeing every udm's dream get crushed
all this time and realizes that he has
to do something about it he tells the
udms that they only need to focus on
what they can do instead of following
the academy's standard he also reveals
that he is actually a udm he is unique
he manages to control the animals to
obey him but only when he is singing
after that he decides to train them to
master their unique magical power
later that night reina is shocked when
she finds chandra waiting for her in her
room
chandra takes the mysterious book away
but somehow the book returns to her desk
the next day the udms begin their
training in the woods the main objective
is to focus on controlling their own
body a few moments later andres is
challenged to fly without relying on his
counterweight bag at first he refuses to
do so since he doesn't know how high he
can fly
scriff manages to convince him and he
finally understands the limit of his
power
meanwhile paloma also becomes confident
with her power elliot is ordered to cast
smoke to get rid of a beehive but he
fails
scrift then has to use his singing power
to control the bees
on the other hand nori is told to create
statues of combined animals as much as
she can to sharpen her visualization
they train hard every day all day all
night and eventually managed to master
their magical power
chandra keeps haunting reina reina also
realizes that chandra is invisible to
other students meaning that only she can
see her that night reina is manipulated
and the shadow magic gains full control
over her body since she finally lets it
in
turns out that the theory is wrong the
shadow magic can possess anyone not only
udms
nori approaches rayna and discovers that
the evil within her is going to destroy
everybody
nori returns to her friends and plans a
strategy to stop reina it's the d-day of
the annual founders day where reyna is
chosen to perform her firebender skill
in front of everybody she purposely
casts a huge fireball and reveals the
shadow magic to the audiences
she transforms into a terrifying huge
creature the students attempt to stop
her but it doesn't work as their magical
powers are just too common and weak
especially the fluxers who transform
into useless animals
a few moments later the udms show up
using his pushing power she prevents the
evil spirit from splitting while elliott
uses his smoke power and andres uses his
flying power to distract it finally nori
transforms herself into a dritten dragon
kitten to twist the creature's body
around
it eventually falls down and miss
nightslinger orders the students to
finish off the creature
nori prevents them from doing so since
reina is her best friend she encourages
her best friend and reyna manages to
destroy the evil spirit from inside
afterwards the headmaster decides to
erase the udm program and students with
unique magical powers are allowed to
take part in the school including scriff
at the end of the movie the mysterious
book falls off the shelf as it opens on
a specific page indicating that the
shadow magic is still there
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching